welcome to this video this is so one
minute bullet tournament that this is
totally confusing to me and why is this
so so strangely fitted into the window
here I can't this was a bit a bit weird
and I'm close to losing one time already
it started even before them it was at
the official starting time and I hadn't
didn't have the the window already
really and I could have taken c7 wow
this would be almost impossible to do
one time 15 seconds with no increment
even with white being a piece up
maybe there is some very slight chance
to do this maybe yep and beep on and
save the day whoo checkmate and somehow
I think the window is quite okay I can I
can do this the recording in this way if
slightly distorted what if I know fix
the window i'll never get anywhere
under the pond here on c4 I know he's
blundering a piece I went the Queen
that's nice okay yeah the video sizes
second is a bit smaller then then I
didn't the last wuzzle and put a
tournament i think i might move a bit a
bit quicker than let's see also sir
indeed the case would be seven porn and
whether the rook is going not to c6
better not to c6 yeah it's really just
just a bunch of material a whole will
appear like to play rook do you want to
get get the D foul
now 25 exchanges queens probably not not
the quickest way to do it go just gave
away the Queen and at least a matter
another shared I am NOT not much
happening here very a closed position
really hope is taking some time only for
my head on c6 clearing up the whole
situation it is not doing that now he's
taking it so it's good maybe I can get
in Queen f2 or something
okay Bishop age five if I would like to
play and I managed to play that maybe
Bishop all the way to age three and now
I can go g5 that's quite quite good
getting the pressure until maybe I can
do something on the gphone he has a hard
time to move away exhibition should be
72 h for asthma as a way to increase
increase the pressure and now 2 g-3 m
yeah no move really I can just take it
be sure before coming
threatening f2 no mate unfortunately
there is no direct checkmate okay this
is this is flowing go on for four give
me a game yeah 96 decent pre-move only
here you should be acutely aware that
there is something threatened trying to
directly attack him here getting a big
lead in development if it takes rook e8
that's the queen yup there is absolutely
no development here for model
King be one Bishop f4 would be cute but
okay get this NTM winning the Queen
that's funny I can also go here to take
d5 winning winning almost every p.m.
twinsies to mate probably coming a nope
rookie well made okay and all this time
I made sure that I'm at least at least
started on time okay and sloth exchange
by transposition galaxy that's a very
good position from white but it's still
a bullet game
brooke has no good square really
come on Roxy 693 now now I take a look
this was the idea dislodging the night
25 yeah I should have probably done
something about it but I don't think
there's really something threatened e 2
that's 92 ya got the Queen at the end
yeah the French let's see Megan getting
some quick play on the fr
okay actually has a trick that I would
wear from what this didn't see it let
okay it's not a big problem I still have
a very substantial compensation may be
here I'm not sure what is the exact move
on i have a very good development
all right look
that's not really so good you managed to
consolidate and now I got one point back
yeah 20 points at the end and too far
apart let's see seven out of seven and i
don't i don't play before yet the moment
of some reason I don't probably I should
most games this is really beneficial to
do and see when wind quicker if they
play a sense of bad stuff on the other
hand with those different openings I'm
normally playing quicker because I
simply and more at home at at the ideas
and more I talking with the ideas and
and know what what to do maybe this way
threatening your final oops forgot about
this one now this looks good for water
okay pushing on the deep own shouldn't
be bad really okay and take it yep so
cruising at the moment but it can easily
change just one or two stupid losses and
yeah you're getting toasted can on this
was a bit passive maybe I can do
something on g2 okay very crude i can do
night hy okay that's it's a good enough
i guess for for good game it would be
great to get in the knight to e5 and to
f3 maybe okay let's cover the du Pont
first and then see if I can get to d3
which is also quite nice I should have
taken g3 though I totally forgot about
that no okay it's not enough really
compensation but it's a bullet game
relax visa lets me take them it's so
surprising
no this is not working out here and let
me get this back
King edge oh this is very strong this is
a pre-movie rook h5 will be deadly green
g2 was much better thank you let's do a
money for for a change what if literally
on this let's work this time this is
this kind of tricks are are great i will
not do not resign this absolutely not we
should be for now if you play more stuff
like f6 i still win the game and
let's see
should I take let me get me to this
first then okay now I get the Queen back
with a totally winning position yeah if
it was playing with the Queen up after
this this trick but still checkmate okay
yeah I don't need you only took a while
so some guy has this over to be this guy
exactly let's see whether this was
stupid ok let's though it's to play
no it's a tough game has gotten quite a
decent rating here no that wasn't very
great idea getting you can play queen of
six now to not do it yeah it wasn't the
only good
I'm not sure if I should trade Queens
away I just blundered the Queen actually
you could have taken it with let's
bullet chess I don't really mind I mean
it happens all the time it's it's one
miniatures not real return them and
stuff they're playing on time is really
doing is really happening all the time I
really like there is also sometimes on
CH s cube this time control 10 second
and then one second increment this is
quite funny sometimes you get to play
that but not in the tournament's okay we
have an isolated greenhorn position
where everything's looking normal but
far behind on the clock IAM getting this
oh they threaten
so tense indian that's not good yeah
okay well position positional subtleties
in in bullet chess now a5 is not really
great iam but ok me when I get some some
tricky nights going c4 hangs 93 here we
go yeah clean f6 without 95 happening or
here this can also be quite tricky let's
zoom yeah look the aid oops I take it
there's no I thought c4 hangs but it
doesn't I can take it down with Quincy
five this is a queen
rucca three would be nice yeah there's
no meat unfortunately I know there is a
maid oops hey I thought he played he
deflects bishop x3 we have to us of
course an immediate made okay I've had
enough material got to be more cautious
with with the brie moves yeah okay q
phonetic is writing a good game this was
the game where one on time which were
not really a good game but okay it
happens oops okay when the French and
oops five that looks very weakening that
can take it but i want i want for
development first in 95 also coming
I can take you form yeah it'sit's bullet
up and wants to play c5 yep oh maybe
night eh oh ok and it didn't happen i
can take and i take an e7 though now i
can take him now while the ship f5 no
would be ok
no I'm very controlling sound very often
Queen g5 would be nice taking on g7 no
mouse sleep instead of exchanging Queens
I blunder 9595 mate in three no okay
Queen g6 green g 6 i'm blue a game ah
now it happens okay so four minutes left
i'm four points ahead i need to get in
two wins would be best if I has some
points at least oops
okay very weird opening like just being
substantially better all-round some
stranger version of the Kings gambit
threatening Bishop between now and I can
take our seven but this is ok didn't
even do it when I can take no slips
happen to all hope it all players once
in awhile it a four year okay better
play play some decent move clearer down
having a slide maybe a slide and Sheila
the better structure now I've given up
on for no particular reason well it's
not totally terrible Queen trade don't
be nice no he creates Quincy and I
cannot play cannot play here and there
not ideal so let's get the king over
trading the bishop
oh come on shouldn't this be enough here
I just lost this one game maybe I get in
a super quick win but it should be
enough really I more than 20 points
ahead no I think I think I manage right
yep gotta win in this thing yeah i
really i really wanted to after I really
crashed her in her in the first bullet
tournament that I had played I think it
was yesterday or the day before that so
at the end I got in got in the win and
only lost this one game with a small
slip yeah and one stupid time when where
I was down like everything but ok in
bullet chess time play is pretty much
the normal thing to do not not much else
that you can do cannot resign all games
for your material down in bullet then it
would be strange ok i hope you enjoyed
this right over 30 minutes thanks for
watching